j'accueille maintenant michèle bernier
j'ai dis pas bonjour si si je déteste
tout le monde
jacques bernier ça va alors donc michel
avant de parler du nouveau film de
claude lelouch je retiens quand même que
le démon de midi oui vous avez
interprété 600 fois sur scène qui a été
vu par cinq cent mille spectateurs
plus passage télé cassettes dvd est en
train de devenir un film voilà oui nous
sommes en plein tournage en ce moment
voilà c'est claude berri qui est produit
encore je suis désolé
la clau claudie doit être par l'anah qui
viennent catherine paul qui vient
d'encourager ses poulains voilà un essai
marie pascale osterrieth dont tu
n'arrive jamais à dire le nom non parce
que réalise voilà voilà et alors ça
sortant et ben écoute je pense printemps
prochain alors aujourd'hui michel vous
êtes avec nous je fais vraiment comme à
la télé là aujourd'hui michel bergue et
vous êtes avec nous pour le nouveau film
de claude lelouch qui s'appelle les
parisiens le premier volet d'une
trilogie intitulée le genre humain et le
film sort le 15 septembre alors c'est à
un casting fleuve à la lellouche il ya
même alexandra kazan c'est pour dire et
robert
robert namias le directeur de la cua on
peut tout faire dans ma vie bien sûr
c'est pas facile habituant le film assez
très vite quand je ferme mon pitch à moi
parce qu'enfin
non non c'est pourtant celle de l'ouche
qu'il définit comme ça imaginons un
satellite espion
survolant notre globe flashantes sur un
échantillon d'individus qui rêve d'être
sur le même échelon d'une échelle
amoureuse de richter exactement voilà
aller avec sa there on est dans le
lautaret résine et il trouve du bloc des
pitch pareil
écoute je crois qu'il a surtout
toujours la passion son métier et
toujours la passion du cinéma et qu'il
aime tellement les gens que je crois
qu'il passera son temps et sa vie à
essayer d'aller filmer ce qu'ils sont et
leur vie leurs angoisses leurs drive il
à vivre plus grands artistes de
l'univers voilà exactement ce que lucian
type c'est un type est on est on
l'aiment pour ça ouais il est influencé
ils vont part lelouch il a fait des
films que j'aime énormément
influencé par toi dites-moi michel c'est
vrai que quand on tourne avec lelouch on
reçoit le scénario après le tournage
je pense que je vais le recevoir
non on n'a pas de scénario c'est
quelqu'un qui parle beaucoup c'est à
dire que moi il m'a dit voilà j'ai envie
de te voir dans une espèce de confidente
éternelle c'est à dire je vais traverser
en fait tous les âges et je vais être là
la gentille confidente de tout un tas de
monde qui souffrent évidemment en
souffrent moi même parce qu'autrement ça
sera pas rigolo et donc dans le film là
je suis là camarades de jeu de mathilde
seigner et on est toutes les deux
semaines
mais moi michel babel un peu trop
et donc on est toutes les deux serveuses
dans un dans un restaurant qui s'appelle
le barbare méridien voilà notre vie
commence parce que on est toutes les
deux amoureuses de deux hommes qui
évidemment ne sont pas amoureux de nous
donc c'est tout le problème de cheveux
mais loti ne veut pas et donc quand
j'aurai celui là bas il voudra plus non
plus donc on passe notre vie
effectivement et chercher le mec ou la
nana qu'on n'aura pas et quand on l'a
eue on passe son temps à s'en
débarrasser alors quoi qu'il en soit
vous êtes devenue une actrice de cinéma
maintenant à part entière un je sais pas
mais en tout cas voilà j'y suis botté
réaction c'est une interview complexe
d'actrice en vitesse comme ça mais
thierry non pour voir à présent mais une
autre pauvre mais d'accord de justesse
des manuels lé mal est bien celle là
elle est bien bah oui est ce que est ce
que vous êtes déjà dix actrices c'est
peut-être pas mon truc finalement non
non vous êtes déjà dit je joue faux nom
j'ai de gros mollets oui
été fait oui je n'aime pas mes yeux ah
non mais ça tombe ou pas du tout bon
qu'est ce qu'il me trouve romane
je t'appelle et ça je le fais alors est
ce que je t'ai déjà dit j'ai des saints
qui tend non non qu'est-ce qu'elle ne
trouve romane ah bah oui ça je me pose
la question parce qu'à chaque fois je ne
crois que ce que je dis ma soeur me
plairont à paris je suis fille unique je
suis jalouse de sherlock non mes fils et
ma fille parce que j'aimerais qu'on
filme comme ils vont en film charlotte
mans oui c'est pourquoi pas oui est ce
que vous vous êtes déjà dit je n'aurai
jamais de ce car c'est la honte devant
mon mari manière parce que j'ai pas de
mari
j'ai pas dans ce cas que ça va ce qui ne
fait pas un carton j'arrête le cinéma on
va pas non la critique ne m'aime pas
c'est vrai n'ont voulu m'agresser il
faut dire non des fois c est ce que vous
êtes déjà dit qu'elle compte se laurent
gerra non
y'a même que j'ai pas osé vous faire que
je vous fais les deux jeunes à faire
aussi angie david est ce que vous êtes
déjà dit non 5 dans un lycée trop quand
même
oui vous avez déjà dit ça c'est dans un
si petit lit que ça m'a
fait déjà dix ans j'ai mis 5 dans un
lycée trop ondes non on est si ça tombe
bien alors on passe à votre vraie
interview au matin mais chez le dernier
c'est l'interview promo de star
catherine barma me dit que claude berri
ne veut pas venir dès ou quoi
je sais pas pourquoi ben conduit demande
pourquoi ne pas venir est ce qu'on peut
demander à claude berri pourquoi il veut
pas mener un système là il lui
compellent coule dans le monde
et qu'on peut le couler dans le métier
c'est la pression ça va qu'est ce qu'il
a prouvé dans la production
bien mais c'est quoi interviews de stars
a battu venant interview promo de ce
passé les écoutes c'est quoi michèle
bernier est ce qu'on peut dire que ce
film c'est d'abord une rencontre
oui est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
d'abord la rencontre avec une histoire
la rencontre avec un réalisateur ou
simplement la rencontre d'un personnage
gérable
c'est d'abord avec un réalisateur parce
que depuis qu ici patrice
j'ai tourné avec tours de louche est en
train ça y est
claude lelouch a su voir en vous au delà
de l'image que vous dégagez généralement
michèle bernier un petit peu de ça c'est
vrai quand même quand il m'a vu dans le
rôle simone keller dans nuit d'ivresse
éternellement ivre morte
je pense qu'il a senti envoie cesse de
fait lui un peu brisé que je trimballe
depuis ma naissance à un père compliqué
puisque avant tout ce film restera une
expérience passionnante avec une équipe
magnifique quelque part une famille je
pense que ce métier est une famille
ouais parce que on se revoit jamais
après les tournages
un peu comme ses cousins et ses cousines
on y pense mais on m'a plu
michel
pour mousser le sait le film de la
maturité
je dirais de ma première et seconde
jeunesse je suis match furent depuis
longtemps mais tellement la vie avec ça
ne se voit pas
c'est un film de la maturité pour les
siècles à venir car je suis éternelle
le seul juge vous êtes d'accord c'est le
public bien sûr qu'à
600 parodié james kelly dans un champ
dans sous la pluie si nous avons pu
mettre un peu de joie dans vos mort-né
un bleu vie ce sera notre récompense
voilà je cinéma c'est du rêve en 24
images secondes michel nom est katherine
ça veut dire
c'est dur de sortir d'un tel rôle on est
on est marqué à jamais guéri parce que
bon je n'avais jamais servi à boire à
quiconque dans ma vie de porter un
costume de serveuse
dans un autre monde où les acteurs ça
m'a apporté énormément j'ai vu à quel
point c'était compliqué pour certaines
femmes de porter un plateau d r pierre
laisse pas sur des mollets quelquefois
grosse bagarre avec débat un petit peu
filmés et d'être souriante autrement
pâte pour licha ma grossesse
très difficile dont j'ai beaucoup appris
quand on vous dit claude aujourd'hui
c'est lellouche si la mort de claude
berri c'est de la merde
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux